Speaker 1: There is something fascinating
and delightful happening since Herschel
Walker lost his election in Georgia on
Tuesday, which is the Republican blame
game. It's your fault. It's your fault.
Hey, who said not to vote early anyway?
That wasn't a good idea. Why didn't more
senators go to Georgia to campaign for
Herschel Walker? They're all pointing fingers.
And the most important takeaway here to me
is this was something they brought on themselves.
We're going to listen to all sorts of different
finger pointing here. We're starting with Ari
Fleischer, former Bush administration official
on the Sean HANNITY program last night saying
you need good candidates starting to point to
the candidate choice. And then HANNITY says,
well, but the Herschel Walker was a good
candidate. This is the best stuff, isn't that?
Speaker 2: Things are so close down the middle.
Yeah, but the final point I'll make, Sean, is
mechanics are always important in campaigns,
but candidate quality is essential. Good
candidates will win. And that big issue for
Republicans still is who is our leader? Who's
the candidate at the top? Oh, I will still has
this opportunity to bring people in.
Speaker 1: So Fleischer seems to both be saying
Trump at the top isn't great for the party, and
Walker also wasn't a particularly good candidate,
but both of which are arguably true.
Speaker 2: Herschel, I thought, was a good
candidate. I know people disagree with that, but
he got outspent and the run off about three to 4
to 1. He got outspent in the general election by
an equal amount. That makes a difference. Money
in politics makes a pretty big difference.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So now all of a sudden,
the concern is money in politics for Sean
HANNITY. Because Walker was a good candidate,
Walker was not a good candidate, but he almost
won anyway because the electorate in Georgia is
so depraved that they thought this guy is a better
option than Raphael Warnock, which is really wacky
stuff. Then sticking with HANNITY for the time
being, HANNITY says, You know, in some cases,
maybe Republicans do actually need to pick
better candidates. And he says not Walker,
but he talks about maybe Doug Mastriano, Michigan.
Speaker 2: In some cases, Republicans do need
better candidates. I'll give you one example not
to pick on Pennsylvania gubernatorial candidate
Doug Mastriano, but you look at his position
on abortion, he had no exceptions for rape,
incest, the mother's life. You in
Pennsylvania? I'm talking politically,
not morally here. You cannot win.
Speaker 1: Morally.
It's all about.
Speaker 2: Pennsylvania.
With that position, it is simply mathematically
impossible, a bad candidate for that race and
it had impact on the entire Republican ticket.
Speaker 1: So this is just interesting because
you've got Ari Fleischer saying Trump at the top
of the ticket isn't good for Republicans. Walker
wasn't a good candidate. Then income's HANNITY
and says, no, Walker was a good candidate,
but Doug Mastriano was not a good candidate.
The finger pointing is starting. Then we go to
Kellyanne Conway. And Kellyanne Conway's message
is the problem is other Republican senators,
it wasn't Herschel Walker. It was that the 49
Republican senators didn't go to Georgia to help
Herschel Walker, a new, new target of her blame.
Speaker 2: I think people saying we need a new
message. Let me just say something respectfully
to the 49 Republican senators. Right. Where were
most of you? Right. Why weren't you in Georgia? A
few of them were, but they all should have been,
gentlemen, because they should have been there
at some point, in some form, a tell a town hall
in person saying the following I serve in the
United States Senate with Raphael Warnock. He's
a terrible senator. He doesn't represent Georgia,
not fit to serve. He voted Joe Biden. He voted
for Inflation Reduction Act. It doesn't do
that. He said nothing when they pulled out
of Afghanistan. He said nothing that Joe Biden's
been to Delaware 174 days and down to the border,
zero days. That's what needs to happen. Where were
the other senators to say, I want Herschel Walker,
not Raphael Warnock in the Senate with me?
Speaker 1: This is absolutely the best. Okay. So
Ari Fleischer says the problem is Trump
at the top of the ticket and Walker is
not a good candidate. HANNITY says no, Walker
was a good candidate. Trump at the top of the
ticket is fine. But Doug Mastriano was a bad
candidate and it was money in politics that
hurt Herschel Walker. Kellyanne Conway says the
problem is the incumbent Republican senators,
they should have been there helping
Herschel Walker. Then we go to Mark Levin,
fox news host. He points out, hey,
republicans aren't explaining their
positions on any issues. That's the problem.
Speaker 3: The reason people. Don't vote as
they don't have a reason to vote. What was
the Republican position on inflation? What
were they going to do? I still don't.
Speaker 1: Know. Well, there was no
position and he's not wrong. I mean, listen,
Mark, Mark Levin is correctly pointing out.
What were they going to do about inflation? Now,
Herschel Walker couldn't even understand what
inflation was. He has no idea what's going on.
You know, up was down. They was night. It was
for Herschel Walker. It was like a twilight zone.
There was no way. That's why Walker didn't express
his position. But why haven't Republicans
explained what they're going to do about
inflation? Well, it's because they can't really do
anything about it. These things are cyclical and
they're global. And you need to figure out what
can we do until inflation comes down? Beyond,
we've talked about what the Fed can do, etc.,
that's an economic discussion. But Mark Levin
is now saying they're not expressing their views
on issues correctly. And then the last clip here
is Charlie Kirk. And he says Republicans aren't
voting because they don't trust the process. Well,
why don't they trust the process? Because
Charlie Kirk's MAGA movement that he is a
part of has been saying you can't trust the.
Speaker 2: Process you say. It's interesting.
I actually assumed incorrectly that if you
take time to watch this program. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 2: That you would
also just automatically vote. Turns out there's
a fair portion of you that are completely done
and that are willing to voice that opinion.
Speaker 1: Why would he think that his program,
which endlessly talks about how everything's
rigged, is going to encourage people to vote?
Speaker 2: Do we have that Laura Ingram clip
that we guys pulled? And I just want to say,
I do sympathize with being upset with the
Republican Party and not totally trusting the
system, but not participating at all. Guarantees
the other side to be able. To play games. And if
everything was broken and lost, how did we win
the House of Representatives? If everything is
broken and lost, how did Ron Johnson, who stood
up against the pharmaceutical company, win?
Speaker 1: Why was he barely won? And Charlie
Kirk is right. Charlie Kirk, of course,
is right. And I ask this question in 2020.
They say the presidential election was rigged,
but all the senators and members of Congress
on the same damn ballots who won there, they
don't say a peep about those. But if it was
rigged, how could there be some incongruent?
And Charlie Kirk is now realizing, well,
all of this talk about it being rigged.
It makes people think it's not worth voting.
And that is exactly what we have been talking
about for a long time. So the finger pointing is
happening. Will they figure it out before 2024?
They very well might. They very well might. We're
going to be here with you. Until then, make sure
you subscribe to our YouTube channel. 3 million
people in October. We're trying to figure it
will gather the number for November soon, 3.2
million of you and in October watched our videos
on YouTube. Didn't subscribe. Please subscribe.
It is free and it does wonders for us in the
YouTube algorithm. We'll take a quick break and
be right back. The David Pakman Show is funded
by none other than you. We have something called
the membership program. You sign up at join pacman
dot com. You get every day, you get the full show
with no commercials hours before everybody else
gets it. You get the bonus show every single
day. Alex Jones hates that damn bonus show.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money. Everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad. Thank
your lucky stars every day you're not back.
Speaker 1: Well, you don't have to be
Dave Packman to get the bonus show you
can sign up at join Pacman dot com you
can use the coupon code 24 starts now and
the next exclusive members only town
hall will be announced very, very soon.